[Applause]
now twitter has basically broken their
rule of neutrality yes which is like
they've had this rule like we're going
to ban regular users we're going to
leave heads of state up
and that's the way we're going to do it
now they've taken trump down
and now there's going to be all these
other national presidents saying okay
what about the president of senegal that
said this against the minority there
what do we do
president of whoever what if putin says
this like what now twitter has to
keep and maintain a level of consistency
in order not does that force politicians
to be more diplomatic
well i think it forces like
international politicians to remove
social media from their
from their societies to remove american
social media
because now they recognize oh jack
dorsey is going to be censoring [ __ ]
that we say and we already
like in turkey they already do this like
erdogan said yo we're not using whatsapp
anymore
we're going to develop a state
centralized whatsapp
for the turkish citizens that we're
going to use and that could potentially
do more harm than good
i mean it basically because america
gives them a tap into their data america
had a strong hold on
like digital colonialism that we were in
every country and any superpower that we
were up against didn't [ __ ] with our
social media right
in russia they don't use google they use
the andex you know what i mean and
i know why china because we basically
have this tool to extract data from all
these other places and it was convenient
for all those other places
just like tik tok exactly yeah that was
the argument for being tick-tock and
most of these countries that were our
allies didn't give a [ __ ] because they
were like at least there's neutrality
and like as long as we don't violate the
rules blah blah blah
twitter is going to play fair with us
but now that twitter has broken
what seems to be like their rule of like
not banning heads of state i
yeah what do we do but now it's like get
me closer to there because i agree with
the digital colonialism right which is
decided like
how do we influence culture social media
is the most influential tool
well we can influence culture around the
world if everybody has this social media
stuff if they're using facebook and then
furthermore
if we need a nudge zuckerberg and say yo
there's an election we might need to
go our way in uh taiwan would you mind
you know like letting people see a few
more ads this this is the worst case
scenario but maybe we could i think it's
completely reasonable
very recently look like there's one
election every four years in america
there are
hundreds of elections around around the
world every year and if we have access
to all those people
in the most uh sophisticated like data
crunched way
to influence them we could have a lot of
influence around the world without
actually like bombing and blowing people
up
so it's pretty amazing so i agree with
the the colonialism the digital
colonialism thing
but what i don't understand is where we
this discrepancy with twitter right now
so it's a different policy that they use
towards trump
but you're saying that they've some sort
like broken this contract globally it's
a precedent now of not just
being neutral with all leaders whereas
before hey guys leaders you post what
you want we don't we're neutral we're
out of it
the second they show an interest which
is we're going to ban you for this
president trump now president prime
minister whoever around the world
you can't be neutral anymore yeah and
then the potential have to be neutral on
twitter
so now if those people if khamenei wants
to say death to israel he just got to
make sure he don't tweet it and then to
that point
to his point then it's like well we
can't say what we really want to say on
twitter so [ __ ] twitter let's
develop our own social media site then
we lose out that on that
then they also lose out on the social
cachet globally right like you know you
can make a twitter story happen globally
if you are invested in this platform
that is global right and that's the
the reason why like neutering trump with
the social media was so powerful is
because
his voice works because so many people
react to his voice so if you remove his
ability to be reacted to
he dies also to the point real quick it
was funny that the second they suspended
him first then we got a video
it was like so soon between hey you're
suspended for
48 hours or whatever it was and then all
right now you get your video yeah
before he wasn't backing out for [ __ ]
yeah yeah and even after suspension he
came back in and that's when he said i'm
not at the inauguration
like saying all this other [ __ ] that was
like twitter i think saw
as dog whistling and like inciting
violence or whatever see so i didn't
know that twitter had that rule with
heads of state
yeah so now that i knew that they have
like
different rules for heads of state than
he shouldn't have gotten
kicked off but now it's like like before
i was like
oh well never violated their rules of
inciting violence well that is true
sorry sorry yeah that applies to
everything
if there's no special uh precaution
right for heads of state when in terms
of like inciting violence
if he is proved to have incited violence
via the app did he tweet something
that's what i think is interesting if
he's not using the app to incite
violence
simply taking him off the app for what
he said off the app
doesn't make sense to me right like if
he's
i don't know like well like he called
people to take a murderer off
twitter he called people to rally that
day but that's what i'm saying his
nuance
his nuance in terms of using the correct
words that you can't say like hey you
said this and
that told everybody to do these violent
acts he's good with that so yes i don't
think you should have kicked them off so
the tricky thing is like
for example you don't want to take off
the black lives matter organizers that
told people to
show up in uh was it kenosha where did
they [ __ ] [ __ ] up
kenosha i think was one of them yeah
minnesota or something like that but
they
took you know they were really lighting
the city up you don't want to take them
off because some [ __ ]
that were part of that peaceful protest
decide to blow things up exactly
so should that same thing be applied to
trump that's what you're saying that's
what i'm saying
if he didn't explicitly say yo go break
some windows and [ __ ] things up exactly
right you can't really take him off for
that you have to prove that that's what
he meant
yes yeah that's an interesting argument
and that's where it comes down i think
like twitter's domain and they say yeah
and they just call balls and strikes and
in this case they chose to pull trump do
you think it's possible sorry to
interrupt do you think it's possible
that
that there are powers that be i don't
know who those powers
are but maybe it's you know a collection
of like the pelosi's the bidens the
schumers these people and maybe the
mitch mcconnell's as well do you think
there's
a collection that essentially call up
big tech and they go hey
he's out of here now we need to do
damage control because it looks like
he's really really
i mean ready to spiral out of control
and really [ __ ] [ __ ] up
we have 10 more days or however many
more days of the presidency
i need you to get him off all platforms
because
for the betterment of our country if
this is the start
if he's willing to start this right now
it's going to just get worse in the next
10 days it could also be twitter saving
phase
so is now like they're like there's
all this like these looming lawsuits of
like trust busting within tech
monopolies
trust busting is like breaking up the
tech monopolies into like multiple
companies and like
anti-trust laws yeah exactly monopoly
yeah
okay so i could see them being like yo
they're going to come down on us after
this whole trump thing and say that we
were complicit and trump's rise to power
blah blah blah
if we just kick them off at the very end
we have all the
social political capital but we also
were like yo we took them off when it
got
out of hand we did the right thing blah
blah blah they have now a case in court
and i think they've been wanting to do
this for a really long time could you
also
to your point though i think i i kind of
agree with you there but also
low-key there's a little part of me
that's like
you [ __ ] scumbags you [ __ ]
profited off of this guy
for four years yeah you made tons of
money got tons of followers we're in the
news
every single day all you tech platforms
banked
off of trump banked off the conspiracies
that he would spew
banked off the people that were
supporting him y'all made billions and
billions of dollars
and now that he's not now that he's gone
now that the cow
is gone that you can't suckle off the
teat you're just gonna sacrifice that
[ __ ] turn into a hamburger back
there because you can still when he's
out office
he's just as you can make just as much
money off of this guy when he's out
while sure
he's gonna keep crying that they stole
the election he's going to keep
saying he's going to run again in four
years he will stay in the news cycle
that's trump's power trump stayed in the
news cycle four years before he was
president saying barack he's the guy
that started barack wasn't born in
america but it wasn't
to me it wasn't the same effect as like
a president has you know like you
you can bump up the new cycle but like
when you have your finger on the nuclear
codes
it's hard to take that as seriously i
think you might
you can still bank a lot you can make a
lot of money you can but don't you agree
less though
sure but i don't think it's so much less
that it's like
i can immediately say oh this is why
you're full of [ __ ] i think they're full
of [ __ ] in a lot of ways
i think they could be doing government
bidding i think they could be whatever i
think it's also possible he was
suspended
and then he came back and then you still
thought he's dog whistling
if we agree with what they thought
earlier to mark's point
then it's like yo we just suspended you
dog what the [ __ ] i dropped
i think this [ __ ] i think that's totally
possible i think this all
this is just like you now you're working
for the feds like
you know what i mean you got you got
away with doing all the [ __ ] [ __ ] for
four years
talking about the big tech companies and
now the feds got you
and they're like see what y'all let
happen see what you did
inspiringness over the last four years
and then
they're like fine i'll flip i'll work
for you guys now what do you want me to
do no that's possible
you know what i mean like i think it's
also possible they've been working with
i think they've
of course you're not going to let
something come to power but go go what
you said about maybe mcconnell and
everybody else calling twitter and being
like yo you gotta get this guy the [ __ ]
out
and then they got him yeah too like this
yeah but to that point
i don't this is why i kind of maybe
believe they had help from within the
government
i don't understand if you're the cia
you're the [ __ ] that we keep
america going at all costs we're gonna
do you know everything
we know everything is going on and we'll
do anything you know what's in my phone
you know when you go to the airport like
there's there's a reason why i am at the
airport bro i'm just saying like
this guy randomly searched and he even
even the one that they're looking for
randomly starts this weekend didn't even
think anything of it i get it
go ahead let's go and what was that site
that got uh taken down or off
star parlor parlor like there were
people talking about this
for weeks and they were even talking
about oh we're coming with our guns
we're coming to [ __ ] it up so
they've seen this they knew it so if you
all knew what was going on
you know about all these terrorist
attacks that don't happen because you
thwart them before they can that's right
and now you're going to act like this
should just happen under your nose
you know what to do when they got to the
capitol we just thought it was gonna be
peaceful ready
obviously so is this one of those
situations where like i don't want to
liken it to pearl harbor but like a lot
of people
say that america knew pearl harbor was
going to happen
and they just needed an excuse to enter
world war ii that galvanized the people
remember you can't do anything in a
country of 300 million people without
the people's support
yeah right like you know you want to
talk about going into iraq you want to
talk about any of these things you need
the people to go yeah we got to go get
them
and did they let this happen so that
they had an excuse
to bury trump because both sides were
like i don't want to deal with this
[ __ ]
rile and [ __ ] up for the next four eight
12 years yeah from a feelings
perspective
like conspiracy wise like is it it seems
sound no
i think that will probably be the
eventual outcome whether or not it's
intentional or not we'll never know
but just from like conspiracy angle like
yeah i think that'll probably be what
happens
man it's just such a okay so then let's
have a
discussion of is a social media platform
a civil right now i don't know if
the metro if the mta is a civil right
is that my right as a new yorker like to
can they say to me well just use another
metro if you don't like us
i think it's hard to say civil right
when it's a publicly traded company
because they
like that's just a company that you use
and then they can always just say like
a civil right i think it is a civil
right because a business can't
turn a person down by service yeah right
and so
i mean unless you highlight some rules
yeah unless you violate the rules
but let's say i violated the rules of
the subway right
could i be banned from the mta or
is that like banning me from walking
down the street no i think it bans you
from the mta
because you violated the rules of the
mta i'm really curious about that i
wonder
so you can't ban me from going into the
park
you can punish me for a criminal act i
commit but the park
is a public place that i can go right so
i wonder if the same thing
will apply to social media as they
become these things that we use
to communicate with the world and our
friends our family as the world
it is like entrenched in our life at
what point do they become a civil right
and then when they do become a civil
right
can you remove it from me and does that
end up being a violation of my first
amendment rights of free speech
yeah i think it has to be government it
has to be paid for by tax dollars
yeah charged admission and you had to
come in to pay a private company to go
to their park
and then you violate a rule and they're
like you can't come to the park anymore
you [ __ ] up at a private thing that's
what if my tax dollars pay for the park
if my tax dollars pay for
the mta if my tax dollars are supporting
facebook
which i think the mca is subsidized but
you still have to pay for it yes
it is and i think it might be a private
organization that is subsidized by the
government i believe so
it is right but so even if that's the
case
it is an interesting space that we're
going into now the interesting one
is i think that there is a push to make
the internet a civil right
right you've had a lot of conversations
about this like uh what was the initial
one that was maybe a few months back
about
they wanted to not have limits to the
amount of internet or something
it was like a big i don't remember that
no this was a big uh
debate uh net neutrality
yeah yeah that's a different thing
that's like yeah allowing different
bandwidths to people who pay more or
less or something yeah that's what
that's what i mean by the limits not
like amount of time but like
uh yeah and i think this net neutrality
thing gave the average person
who want to start a website the same uh
real estate if you will
on the internet as like some big company
so it allowed a startup to propagate
because
you didn't have to compete with [ __ ]
target or walmart in terms of your usage
of the internet
but i go go no i don't know i just
wonder if like
i wonder if as these things become like
parts of our life in the same way
water is you know i know it sounds crazy
to think of the internet as like water
or heat or these things that are
supposed to be provided but
it could be ubiquitous yeah i view the
internet as like the street
you know what i mean like assuming that
you aren't like in violation of like
the law of that area and you should be
in jail like you should be allowed to
walk down the street
that doesn't mean you should be allowed
to go into any business you want to
assume that you violate the rules of
that specific business you can't punch
someone on the street
right so you have to obey the rules of
the street
and you are allowed to be barred from
the private businesses that reside on
the street
so if that's the case does the
government and therefore
the people decide the rules of the
internet those internet sites
once it becomes the street and not jack
dorsey at twitter
yeah i think it has to right now because
it's like
you're just giving them the right to get
on the internet once you're on the
internet if you go to
a any site that site is owned by
somebody the internet is a street
this website is the store within it yeah
the store sits on any of the stores
whether they be websites social media
those are
all private stores yeah homeless guy can
walk around the street
that's not technically a law or illegal
but if a homeless guy goes into a
restaurant they can
say get the [ __ ] out yeah okay what is
facebook then a mall
you know how homeless people can be in a
mall
right and because the mall is
essentially public
property like these outdoor mall or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
like you can't i don't think you can
remove homeless people from i think you
can
you can i mean i've been kicked out of a
bunch of malls in my life fair enough
what yeah they're in high school
for what i remember this was a big story
like a second year in dallas you got
kicked out of them all for sagging
hilarious
really yeah i mean what did you get we
were filming a video in the mall and the
cops were
like the mall security was like you
can't be in here and they kicked us out
reasonable it's happened like three or
four times reasonable shouldn't be
filming in the mall
[ __ ] kids i'm a kid i was a kid at
the time
whatever kids can't do that to kids so
[Laughter]
i don't know it's just a weird time do
you think trump gets impeached
i mean time is running out boy you got
nine days or something like that
but they can continue with it after yeah
i don't know how that works
you can continue you're gonna impeach
even after he's gone yeah so it's so
embarrassing
you're out you're at home yeah then you
remove and then you find out you gotta
be come on
bro yeah but i think then you're just
removing all those
different like luxuries that you have
from being president
right okay which he doesn't really
[ __ ] need i think it's just how do we
remove this guy from potentially running
again from primary
primary running in the primaries running
in the primaries
yeah that's what they want they're just
worried about they're trying to remove
his political capital
and it's a [ __ ] ballsy move but he's
making it very easy for them
you